Herzlich willkommen zu unserer ersten Folge Dicke Bretter in diesem Jahr.
Es ist Folge 12 und kleine Informationen vorweg. Wir zeichnen am 10.02.
Auf, das heißt vor den Bundestagswahlen. Deswegen kann sein,
dass einige Informationen vielleicht veraltet sind oder nicht,
je nachdem, wann diese Folge erscheint.
Ich bin Elina und heute bin ich mal wieder mit Konstanze hier und wir wollen
uns diesmal ein Policy-Thema angucken, aber auch ein sehr juristisches Thema.
Nämlich, naja, man kann fast sagen, strategisches Klagen, vielleicht auch nicht so strategisch.
Das werden wir uns gleich mal anschauen und dafür haben wir uns auch einen Gast
eingeladen, nämlich Snoopy.
Snoopy ist, genauso wie Konstanz und ich, Teil des CCC-Sprecher-Innen-Team,
organisiert die FrostCon und ich kenne Snoopy eigentlich so aus E-Trie-Dingen.
Solange ich E-Trädinge mache, macht Snoopy schon länger E-Trädinge.
Ganz besonders in dem Bereich Reclaim Your Faces, das heißt biometrische Massenüberwachung.
Und er ist auch Teil einer Initiative, die Kameras stoppen heißt und darum soll
es gehen. Hallo Snoopy, hallo Konstanze.
Hallo.
Und ja, Snoopy, warum bist du heute hier?
Kameras stoppen ist dein Thema und was hat das mit Policy-Sachen zu tun?
Ja genau, Kameras stoppen, das ist der Name einer Initiative,
die wir in Köln vor einiger Zeit gegründet haben und die Initiative wendet sich
so ein bisschen gegen Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum,
vor allem durch staatliche Institutionen, hier auch Polizei.
Und was das mit Policy zu tun hat, weil sich dieses gesamte Verfahren,
weil wir auch so ein bisschen rüstisch dagegen vorgehen,
so lange zieht, sehen wir im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen den ganzen Gesetzgebungsprozessen
nebenher von der Seitenlinie zu und unterhalten uns da halt auch so ein bisschen um Policy-Dinge.
Also was sollte gemacht werden und wie sehen so Gesetze dann am Ende aus,
wenn sie beschlossen werden und wie kann man daran noch was ändern oder wo gibt es dann Probleme?
Also wir haben ja den Podcast immer dicke Bretter genannt von Anfang an.
Und jetzt hast du Policy so ein bisschen eng ausgelegt.
Wir wollen ja eigentlich so ein bisschen darstellen, wie politische Meinungsbildung
stattfindet, wie man aber auch im netzpolitischen Bereich dicke Bretter bohrt,
indem man zum Beispiel eben strategische Gerichtsverfahren führt.
Und was du jetzt noch nicht erwähnt hast, ist, was für ein dickes Brett eigentlich euer Verfahren ist.
Denn jetzt Ende letzten Jahres, als vom Verwaltungsgericht Köln diese Verhandlung
war, da waren ja schon viele Jahre vergangen. Denn ihr wendet euch gegen eine
polizeiliche Willi-Überwachung, die seit 2016 läuft.
Sind also jetzt neun Jahre, nicht ganz.
Richtig, genau.
Also da geht es ja um mehr als nur Policy in diesem engeren Sinne,
Politikgestaltung, sondern eben auch, wie man versucht, auch langfristig zu engagieren.
Und das ist auch ein Grund, warum wir dich eingeladen haben,
sozusagen, um diesen Aspekt zu besprechen und auch mal ganz praktisch,
wie man das eigentlich macht.
Genau, vielleicht können wir
da ja einhaken. Konz hat ja gerade schon ein Verwaltungsgerichtsverfahren
erwähnt und du hast gesagt Kameras stoppen, ihr beschäftigt sich auch irgendwie
mit den Gesetzen so am Rande,
aber noch viel wichtiger, ihr habt auch eine Klage am Laufen und da ist ja erstmal
vielleicht die Frage vorweg, was gesagt ihr seid in Köln, wogegen klagt ihr
überhaupt und was ist eigentlich in Köln los, dass man klagen muss?
Genau, bevor ich da einsteige, nochmal als Ergänzung zu dicke Bretter.
Also es sind insgesamt über 1500 Seiten schriftsätzliches Material,
von dem wir hier irgendwie reden, wenn wir über die Klage reden.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein wirklich eher dickeres Brett, also wenn man sich
das so versucht vorzustellen.
Das sind, ich glaube, über 10 Leitzordner, da ist einiges zusammengekommen.
Und genau, worum geht es eigentlich?
Alles fing so ein bisschen an in der Kölner Silvesternacht 2015, 2016.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch einfach daran, was damals passiert ist.
Es ging darum, dass in dieser Silvesternacht in Köln von 2015 auf 2016 es viele.
Missbrauchsübergriffe im Bereich um den Dom gab und die Polizei Köln bzw.
Die Polizei NRW da auch doch eher versagt hat, damit umzugehen und rechtzeitig
die passenden Maßnahmen einzuleiten, um die Leute irgendwie zu schützen oder
sich darum zu kümmern, dass das gestoppt wird.
Und infolge dieser Aufarbeitung gab es dann auch so ein bisschen diesen Willen,
Jetzt müssen wir was machen.
Und da wurden dann einige Sicherheitsmaßnahmen beschlossen und entschieden und
eine davon ist zum Beispiel die Videoüberwachung, die da dann nochmal konkreter ausgebaut wurde.
Und die hat dann auch am Kölner Hauptbahnhof im Prinzip Dom und also das ist
so ein bisschen die Vorderseite vom Hauptbahnhof, wer den Ort kennt und direkt
auch auf der Rückseite Breslauer Platz,
wenn man quasi durch den Hinterausgang Richtung U-Bahn-Haltestelle geht,
da ist dann die Videoüberwachung gebaut worden.
Es müsste so um März 2016 sein, ab wann das da anfing.
Also so schon einigermaßen früh danach.
Aber war die Party nicht vor allen Dingen der ausschlaggebende Grund?
Also es ist richtig so diese Feierlichkeiten, ist ja dann auch finster.
Ist ja tatsächlich so eine direkte Begründungslinie, weil Videoüberwachung ja
auch ein bisschen Lichtsituationen braucht und so, da ist ja eigentlich relativ dunkel gewesen.
Wird das ernsthaft als Gegenmaßnahme gegen so eine Übergriffe verkauft oder
ist das nur so eine zeitliche Korrelation?
Das ist auf jeden Fall, also das ist auch eine zeitliche Korrelation,
aber wenn man sich so ein bisschen die Hardware, worauf wir bestimmt gleich
noch so ein bisschen sprechen werden,
zurückkommen, die haben schon eher die gute Hardware gemacht,
die auch im Dunkeln wohl einigermaßen brauchbare Bilder liefert.
Mhm.
Ist noch mehr als Hauptbahnhof? Also du hast jetzt den Breslauer Platz,
die Rückseite, dann die Domplatte, da war ja noch ein bisschen mehr, oder?
Richtig. Nachdem das dort ausgebaut wurde, wurden dann weitere Plätze mit Kameras ausgestattet.
Und zwar haben wir dann einmal so ein bisschen die Kölner Party-Szene auf den Ringen.
Später ging es dann ein bisschen darum, die Videoüberwachung in Richtung Drogenkriminalität
auszubauen, um da irgendwie zu versuchen, etwas zu machen, damit die Situation besser wird.
Deshalb wurde dann auf dem Ebertplatz und dem Neumarkt weiter ausgebaut.
Und später ging der Ausbau dann weiter mit dem Wiener Platz in Köln.
Das war für uns auch eine Überraschung, weil damit war ein Platz,
der so ein bisschen außerhalb von dem Innenstadtbereich, wo viel los ist und
viel Action ist, wo man ja vielleicht so ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann,
warum es da Sinn ergibt, etwas hinzubauen.
Dann auch mit dem Wiener Platz, der ein bisschen außerhalb ist.
Und dann die letzte Sache, die wurde auch jetzt relativ neu ausgebaut und zwar in Kalk.
Da gab es dann auch so ein bisschen Berichterstattung von Netzpolitik.org.
Und das ist auch nochmal die Fortführung, dass sie die Dimension ändert,
weil es da auch in ein Wohnviertel reingeht.
Das sind ja nicht diese Innenstadtplätze, die wir jetzt irgendwie am Hauptbahnhof,
am Ebertplatz haben, sondern da reden wir dann schon von Wohngebieten, wo Leute leben.
Ja und wer sich das nicht so gut vorstellen kann, weil Köln vielleicht einem
außer Karneval und Dom nichts sagt, Ihr habt auf eurer kamerasstoppen.org Webseite,
das machen wir auch nochmal in die Shownotes,
eine ziemlich gute Karte, wo man sich das angucken kann, wo diese ganzen Videostandorte
sind und ich habe mir das irgendwie vor der Aufzeichnung angeguckt und ich finde
es schon krass, wie viele Bereiche das sind am Ende des Tages.
Du hast jetzt auch gesagt, das ist in Wohngebieten.
Ich finde Kameraüberwachung generell immer ziemlich gruselig,
aber so diesen Gedanken zu haben, okay, immer wenn ich aus meiner Haustür gehe,
guckt irgendwie die Polizei Köln mir dabei zu, das ist ja irgendwie schon krass.
Richtig, das ist halt genauso, wie es dann ist und in Kalk halt verstärkt auch
nochmal in diesen Wohngebieten.
Und das ist halt wirklich, ja, echt eine gruselige Vorstellung.
Und mit welcher Begründung haben Sie das in diese Wohngebiete gemacht?
Also gab es da eine Begründung oder ist das jetzt eher so ein vorsichtiges Ausbreiten
von Videoüberwachungsmaßnahmen in der gesamten Stadt Köln?
In Kalk geht es so ein bisschen darum, das Viertel, in dem die Videoüberwachung
ausgebaut wurde, hat auch so ein bisschen soziale Probleme.
Man sieht einige Obdachlose dort,
Straßenbild, es gibt Drogenkriminalität und da ist dann die Kalk-Mülheimer Straße
auch sehr bekannt für in dem Viertel und auch so in Köln und die ist auch videoüberwacht,
aber sie haben die Videoüberwachung deutlich über diese Hotspots hinaus ausgeweitet.
Also bis quasi in den nächsten Stadtteil Humboldt-Kremberg auch rein.
Und da ist eine sozial schwierige Situation, die man jetzt mit Kriminalitätbekämpfungsmaßnahmen
eindämmen möchte, einfach nicht sinnvoll.
Jetzt haben wir das ja am Anfang schon erwähnt. Ihr habt 2016 die Klage eingereicht.
2016 ist die Kammerüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum eingeführt worden.
Jetzt hast du die beschrieben, wo die ist in Köln und dass die mittlerweile
in Wohngebiete vorgeht.
Habt ihr denn im Rahmen der, zu sagen, wenn man jetzt mal so aus der Prozesssicht
beschreibt, habt ihr denn jeweils immer die Klage erweitert,
um weitere, wie die Überwachung nicht hinzugekommen ist oder wie läuft das dann
praktisch, wenn man bereits eine Klage laufen hat?
Ja, das ist auch eine ganz spannende Frage,
denn wie du schon sagst, die Polizei hat die Videoüberwachungsbereiche immer
so ein Stück weit erweitert und alles losging im Prinzip mit der Videoüberwachung am Hauptbahnhof.
Und dort hat es dem Kläger dann einfach gereicht, nachdem klar wurde,
okay, diese Videoüberwachung soll noch ein bisschen ausgeweitet werden und dann haben wir bzw.
Der Kläger mit uns zusammen, also ich sage jetzt mal uns, aber ich war damals
bei der Klageeinreichung noch nicht in der Kampagne drin, deshalb kann ich da
auch nur so ein bisschen aus zweiter Hand berichten,
Klage eingereicht und nachdem sich diese Klage so lange gezogen hat,
weil das alles dauert, wir haben auch rechtlich schwierige Fragen aufgeworfen.
Die Kammer, die das entscheiden sollte, hat jetzt auch nicht besonders schnell gehandelt.
Es gab viele Argumente, die ausgetauscht wurden und damit haben wir dann einen
Stand erreicht, wo die Verhandlung noch mittendrin
war, aber schon weitere Videoüberwachungsbereiche ausgebaut wurden.
Und dort sind wir dann hingegangen, okay, wir stellen die Videoüberwachung grundsätzlich in Frage,
aber bevor das entschieden ist, ändert die Polizei durch weitere Maßnahmen im
Prinzip schon die Realität, obwohl das Ergebnis noch nicht festgestellt ist.
Und dann hat man die Möglichkeit, ein Eilverfahren anzustrengen,
indem man sagen kann, okay, wir haben hier ein Verfahren, wo wir überhaupt klären
wollen, ob das, was die Polizei macht, rechtlich überhaupt zulässig ist.
Und dann geht die Polizei hin und macht aber noch weitere Maßnahmen, die genauso sind.
Und da möchten wir jetzt eine vorläufige Entscheidung haben,
bis das in der Hauptsache geklärt ist.
Das haben wir dann mit verschiedenen Plätzen gemacht und zwar haben wir die
Eilverfahren einmal beim Ebertplatz,
Neumarkt und Breslauerplatz dann angestrebt, nachdem die Plätze im Prinzip weiter
mit Videoüberwachung bebaut wurden.
Für die Zuhörerinnen, die sich vielleicht noch nicht so mit Klagen und so auskennen,
was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Eilverfahren und einem Hauptverfahren
und wieso habt ihr euch für diese unterschiedlichen Verfahren entschieden?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Also vor allem möchte ich hier nochmal betonen, ich bin kein Jurist.
Ich beschäftige mich nur ein bisschen damit und bitte versteht es nicht als,
dass was ich sage, ist alles hundertprozentig richtig.
Ich versuche aber natürlich schon, es richtig wiederzugeben.
Und zwar ist das ein Verfahren so ein bisschen, dass man…,
sieht, okay, hier wird eine Realität geschaffen, obwohl die Frage noch nicht
geklärt ist und jetzt möchte ich vorläufigen Rechtsschutz.
Also ich möchte, dass zumindest ein Gericht mal ganz grob ein paar Punkte diese
Situation überprüft und dann eine vorläufige Entscheidung trifft,
die ganz auf leichter Ebene geprüft ist, ob das, was hier passiert,
eher rechtmäßig ist oder eher nicht.
Und dann wird die eigentliche Sache immer noch in einem Hauptverfahren entschieden,
aber mit dem Eilverfahren gibt es dann im Prinzip schon mal einen Vorentscheid,
was das Gericht meint, in welche Richtung quasi wahrscheinlicher ist.
Und ein bisschen davon wegführend, was ich mich natürlich jetzt auch frage,
wenn du sagst, okay, wir haben diese Verfahrenswege gesucht,
um bestimmte Sachen zu klären, wo waren eigentlich die Datenschutzbehörden,
als die Polizei gesagt hat, jo, wir machen das jetzt mal und rollen hier Videoüberwachung auf.
Also ich hätte jetzt irgendwie gedacht, dass da ein Datenschutzbeauftragter
dann auch mal sagt, naja, also Wohngebiete, Videoüberwachung passt irgendwie
nicht so ganz zusammen, oder?
Das ist richtig. Die zuständige Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde ist die Landesbeauftragte
für Datenschutz- und Informationsfreiheit NRW und die hat sich auch so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt.
Es gab am Anfang, nachdem das gebaut wurde, auch mal eine Kontrolle,
in der die Datenschutzbeauftragte das ein bisschen kontrolliert hat und es gab Beanstandungen.
Eine der Beanstandungen war, dass die Videoüberwachung nicht 24-7 notwendig
ist, sondern auch ausreichend sein sollte, um den Zweck zu erfüllen,
wenn man für bestimmte Belastungszeiten, wo viel passiert, zum Beispiel,
wenn wir jetzt über die Partylocations reden, dann so in den Abend- und Nachtstunden.
Oder am Hauptbahnhof, so eher über die Tagstunden, wo einfach sehr viel Verkehr
und vielleicht auch Tourismus und Publikum da unterwegs ist.
Und da hat die Datenschutzbeauftragte NRW zum Beispiel gesagt,
ja, das sehen wir anders, dass hier eine 24-7-Überwachung notwendig ist,
sondern das sollte zeitlich eingeschränkt werden.
Und sonst haben wir gesehen, dass die Datenschutzbeauftragte nicht besonders viel tut.
Was genau sie getan hat, haben wir dann auch mal per Informationsfreiheitsgesetz
ein bisschen erfragt, um zu schauen, okay, was ist denn hier jetzt genau passiert?
Und da haben wir ein paar Dokumente zurückbekommen, die zeigen,
dass es eine leichte Prüfung gab mit dem Hinweis, hier muss Dinge verbessert werden.
Und man sieht, dass die Polizei sich sehr viel Zeit lässt, diese Verbesserung
umzusetzen und auch teilweise gar nicht umgesetzt hat.
Aber muss sie auch nicht. Eine Rechtspflicht besteht ja nicht.
Das sind ja quasi nur so Hinweise. Diese Beanstandungen haben ja keine,
kann man nicht wirklich eine rechtliche Verbindlichkeit für die Polizei, oder?
Das ist auch eine sehr gute Frage. Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ja, man kann die Polizei als Datenschutzbehörde zumindest hier,
glaube ich, eher schlecht versuchen zu erzwingen, das genauso zu tun,
wie man das selbst für richtig hält als Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde.
Ja, also wir hatten ja am Anfang schon mal auf unseren Titel hingewiesen,
den ich hier nochmal nenne, dicke Bretter.
Es ist aber die gesamte Debatte um die Videoüberwachung ist ja auch von der
anderen Seite ein dickes Brett.
Also wenn ich jetzt mal sozusagen diejenigen in den Blick nehme,
die sich schon sehr lange und auch relativ laut für Videoüberwachung einsetzen.
Du hast erwähnt, die Klage ist vom Juli 2018. Da ging es erstmal los am Bahnhof
und generell ist die Überwachung an Bahnhöfen ja in diesen acht Jahren,
die da jetzt vergangen sind, enorm gewachsen.
Gerade vor wenigen Wochen hat das Bundesministerium des Innern,
jetzt kurz vor der Wahl, sicherlich auch mit ein bisschen mit dem Wahlkampf
im Blick, ein paar aktuelle Zahlen veröffentlicht.
Wir haben derzeit in bundesdeutschen Bahnhöfen, nämlich an allen großen Bahnhöfen,
750 Stück, 11.000 Kameras. Also hier sind ja einfach in der Zeit,
in der ihr den Klageweg da mühsam gegangen seid, Fakten geschaffen worden.
Die Innenministerin, die Sozialdemokratin ist und derzeit noch Nancy Faeser
heißt, hat gesagt, wir stellen damit mehr Sicherheit her.
Sie hat auch ein paar Zahlen genannt über die Aufklärung von Kriminalfällen,
die sich seit 2019 verdreifacht hätten.
Also da ist ja auch von der anderen Seite was passiert. 180 Millionen hat der Bund investiert,
Und wie würdest du in Relation zu der Klage sozusagen diesen Fakten schaffen
auf der anderen Seite sehen?
Also das ist ja so ein bisschen, als wenn man sich einen Tropfen auf dem heißen
Stein gießt. Oder siehst du das anders?
Auf der einen Seite gebe ich dir recht, dass es sich auf jeden Fall so anfühlt,
als würde man einen Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein gießen.
Wie du schon sagst, man sieht das überall, die Videoüberwachung auch.
Ich habe teilweise das Gefühl, so als Allheilmittel, wir bauen Videoüberwachung
auf und jetzt ist es sicher.
Ja, das ist so mein Gefühl, wie es manchmal argumentiert oder benutzt wird und
genau da ist natürlich, wenn wir jetzt das so versuchen, ein bisschen isoliert zu betrachten,
das, was wir jetzt klagemäßig machen, im Prinzip nur ein Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein.
Aber auf der anderen Seite sind wir
gerade dabei, so ein paar juristisch grundsätzliche Dinge festzustellen.
Es geht ja auch viel um die Grundrechte, also das informationelle Recht auf
Selbstbestimmung oder auch das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung,
insbesondere in Bezug auf Versammlungen, die da immer eine Rolle spielen und
die wir damit mit den Klagen so grundsätzlich erweitern.
Im Prinzip, also das ist auch so ein bisschen die Idee hinter unseren Klagen,
dass wir im Prinzip unsere Grundrechte stärken.
Heißt das auch ganz praktisch, ihr wollt, wenn ihr irgendwann mal die Verwaltungsgerichtsebene
hinter euch gelassen habt, auch gerne...
Zu sagen, auf die Grundrechtsebene, etwa zum Bundesverfassungsgericht mal irgendwann
kommen oder zum EuGH. Also strebt jeder tatsächlich auf diese strategische Weise an?
Das ist so ein bisschen auch schwierig. Also ganz irrig angenommen,
das Bundesverwaltungsgericht würde sagen, okay, ja, die Videoüberwachung ist
viel zu stark eingreifend in die Grundrechte.
Das muss stark eingeschränkt werden oder sogar abgebaut werden.
Das glaube ich eher noch nicht, dass das passieren wird.
Aber, also dann wäre auch vielleicht kein Weg vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht
notwendig, aber das ist so ein bisschen das Konzept, was am Ende dann auch dahinter
stehen muss, weil wir haben festgestellt,
auch leider erst während des Verfahrens, dass diese Dinge auch für die Gerichte so ein bisschen,
okay, wie machen wir das jetzt mit Videoerwachung und Grundrechten durch die
Polizei, dass das für die jetzt auch nicht so alltäglich war und dass sie da
viele komplizierte Fragen sehen.
Okay, das heißt also, da ist eigentlich noch ganz viel Raum,
um Fragen zu klären, nehme ich an.
Vielleicht können wir noch mal ein paar Schritte wieder zurück machen.
Wir haben ja kurz über Eilverfahren und Hauptverfahren gesprochen.
Du meinst, du warst nicht von Anfang an bei der Klage dabei,
aber ich finde es irgendwie trotzdem mal wichtig, so den Leuten mit auf den Weg zu geben.
Wie macht man eigentlich so eine Klage?
Wie habt ihr das damals aufgezogen? Also ich vermute mal, wenn Wohngebiete auch
betroffen waren, habt ihr wahrscheinlich mit Betroffenen gearbeitet.
Das ist ja irgendwie immer elementar, wenn man solche Klagen anstrebt.
Aber wie seid ihr da vorgegangen? Habt ihr euch irgendwie zusammengefunden?
Habt ihr irgendwie einen Aufruf gestartet? Wie habt ihr das gemacht?
Genau, das ist natürlich richtig, dass wenn es um Wohngebiete geht,
dass es auch sinnvoll ist, die passenden Betroffenen zu finden,
um mit denen zu reden und zu schauen,
sehen die das auch so problematisch und haben sie Lust mitzuhelfen,
dieses Projekt zu bearbeiten.
Und bei uns fing das ja schon vor dieser ganzen Sache, wo das in die Wohngebiete ging an.
Deshalb hatten wir diese Wohngebiete auch nicht so auf unserer Agenda.
Das hat sich erst vor allem mit Kalk nochmal deutlich verschärft.
Aber davor ging es ja vor allem um Hauptbahnhof und die Gebiete um den Dom.
Und da ging es auch so ein bisschen darum, wir, beziehungsweise der Kläger hat
es wahrgenommen, der ist auch politisch durchaus ein bisschen aktiv,
nimmt an Versammlungen teil und der hat sich einfach davon gestört gefühlt,
dass während Versammlungen, die auch gerne am Hauptbahnhof, am Dom vorkommen.
Dass die Planung ist, die Videoüberwachung noch weiter auszuweiten und hat sich
entschieden, dagegen im Prinzip einen Riegel vorschieben zu wollen,
damit das nicht weiter eskaliert.
Und ja, es ist natürlich schwierig, sowas zu machen. Man braucht verschiedene
Mittel, um sowas stemmen zu können.
Also einerseits natürlich immer die Frage des Finanziellen, weil Klagen kostet
Geld, man muss Leute dafür bezahlen, man muss die Gerichte bezahlen.
Und dann hilft es natürlich auch, gute Kontakte in die lokalen Gruppen,
sei es aktivistisch oder wie auch immer geartet, um da Rechtsbeistände zu finden,
die einen dabei unterstützen.
Und da sind diese Kontakte dann auch sehr hilfreich und deshalb hat das auch
überhaupt funktioniert.
Also was wusstet ihr eigentlich über die Videoüberwachung an sich und über die Technik?
Also vielleicht kannst du dazu was sagen und vor allen Dingen auch im Vergleich
zu am Anfang und was ihr jetzt nach all den Jahren verfahren wisst,
mal in der Annahme, dass ihr einige in den Papieren, die während des Gerichtsverfahrens
dann so auflaufen, gefunden habt.
Was wisst ihr darüber heute, was
da eigentlich verbaut ist und was da auch technisch im Hintergrund läuft?
Ja, am Anfang wussten wir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel darüber.
Wir haben die halt gesehen, die sahen halt beeindruckend aus.
Also wenn ihr euch so eine Kamera mal anschaut,
die aktuell in Köln verbaut ist, dann seht ihr so einen weißen Kasten und wenn
ihr da so ein bisschen weiter hinschaut, dann ist das halt nicht so eine kleinere Kamera,
die man jetzt vielleicht so als Webcam benutzt.
Also diese kleinen, die jetzt eher nicht so, also so Dimensionen,
irgendwie so ein Tennisball.
Und hier haben wir halt eher größere Kästen, die so in Richtung Schuhkarton gehen.
Und dann, wenn man da genauer hinschaut, sieht man, dass da acht Objektive im Prinzip drin sind.
Und das ist schon so ein bisschen gruselig, finde ich, weil das nach deutlich
stärkerer Hardware aussieht, als man jetzt von so Überwachungskamera aus den U-Bahnen oder so kennt.
Und wir haben im Klageverfahren schon einiges über diese Videoüberwachung und
den Hersteller der Videoüberwachung gelernt.
Also der Hersteller, das kann man sehen, weil das auch auf den Geräten alles
draufsteht, ist Dallmeyer.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Kaffeebohnenhersteller.
Der wird glaube ich mit Y geschrieben und der für die Videoüberwachung wird mit EI geschrieben.
Also so kann man das erkennen. Und der Hersteller kommt so ein bisschen aus
dem Bereich Casino-Spielhallen, wo es glaube ich auch teilweise verpflichtend
ist, die Spieltische irgendwie zu überwachen, um Betrug zu erkennen.
Und das ist so, womit der Hersteller auf jeden Fall damals geworben hat,
wo der auch so ein bisschen herkommt, was so sein Bereich ist mit seiner Expertise.
Und da sich dann irgendwie durch den Klageprozess und Anfragen, okay, genau passiert.
Eine der zentralen Themen, die uns bewegt haben, war, wurde die Videoüberwachung
bei einer Versammlung ausgeschaltet.
Oder nicht? Und wenn ja, kann die Polizei das irgendwie nachweisen?
Oder wurde ich auch auf dieser Versammlung erfasst oder nicht?
Weil es gibt ja bestimmte Auskunftsrechte, die haben wir geltend gemacht.
Und da kam dann so für jemanden, der nicht so viel mit IT zu tun hat,
ein bisschen kryptische Protokolle und Datenblätter zurück von der Polizei nach
so ein bisschen Klageverfahren und Bitten und Nachhaken.
Und das ist im Prinzip so ein bisschen die Geschichte, wie ich da reingerutscht
bin, weil irgendwann standen die bei uns beim CCC Köln bzw.
C4 vor der Tür und haben uns im Prinzip diese Protokolle hingehalten und gefragt,
kann uns das bitte jemand erklären? Dann habe ich gesehen, oh Videoüberwachung,
das ist aber interessant.
Dann habe ich mir das angeguckt und seitdem bin ich da so reingerutscht,
weil das einfach praktisch war, dass die dann auch mich hatten,
der aus technischer Sicht einfach so ein bisschen die Protokolle oder technischen
Daten in einen Kontext rücken kann,
damit die Polizei es nicht schafft, uns Bären aufzubinden, um zu schauen,
okay, das war ja nichts, hier sind die Protokolle, könnt ihr ja sehen,
das war alles total harmlos.
Sondern da können wir dann mit ein bisschen Expertise das dann auch selbst nachvollziehen.
Sag mal noch ein bisschen was zu der Technik noch dahinter. Also die Sachen
konnte man ja vielleicht noch sehen, die Hardware.
Und wenn man sich vielleicht ein bisschen mit den typischen Firmen,
die Vertragspartner der Parteien sind, vielleicht noch ahnen.
Aber was da ganz im Hintergrund läuft, das kann man natürlich nicht wissen.
Sag mal was zu der Verarbeitung der eigentlichen Videosignale.
Genau, also nachdem sich die Klage so ein bisschen fortgesetzt hat,
haben wir auch Datenblätter vom Hersteller gesehen und bekommen und ausgewertet und begutachtet.
Ich gehe nochmal ganz kurz auf diese Kamerageschichte ein.
Und zwar nennen sie dieses eine Modell, dieses Schuhkarton mit den mehreren
Objektiven, Multifokus-Kamera.
Und die haben das Feature, dass in einem Gehäuse mehrere Objektive mit eigenen Fotosensoren sind.
Und da können die im Prinzip, wenn man sich so ein bisschen versucht vorzustellen,
oben sind Objektive mit so einer Telefon, also mit einem Zoom als Teleobjektive,
die weit in einen Raum reingucken können.
Und dann sind da noch Objektive drin, die eine Übersichtsaufnahme erstellen
können und das Feature davon ist, dass die Kameras einen sehr großen Bereich überdecken können,
ohne dass man im Prinzip, wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, man hat eine Kamera,
mit der zoogt man rein und wenn man reinzoogt, dann verliert man ja den Blick
rechts und links neben den Bereichen, die am Zoom vorbeigehen.
Und da ist der Trick, dass ich durch diese Übersichtsobjektive,
die immer noch im Hintergrund laufen,
da eine Flächenüberwachung hinbekommen und die können auch im Nachhinein hingehen
und in einen Ausland reinzoomen und dann woanders hin reinzoomen.
Das ist so ein bisschen das, was das Überwachungspotenzial auch nochmal höher macht.
Die können jederzeit im Prinzip wieder zurückgehen und woanders reinzoomen.
Okay, das ist jetzt aber sozusagen technisch erstmal, würde ich mal sagen, ein gutes Angebot.
Und was man heute technisch kann, aber das ist ja noch nicht unbedingt die Auswertung.
Wie ist es denn mit der Auswertung der Daten? Ist da irgendeine Automatisierung dabei?
Das ist auch eine Frage, die hat uns länger beschäftigt.
Die Polizei sagt, dort ist keine automatisierte Auswertung vorhanden.
Das hat auch das Gericht gesagt, dass die Polizei das immer wiederholt hat und
auch in den Gerichtsverfahren gesagt hat, dass es so ist. Und damit ist das halt auch so.
Wir sehen beim Hersteller, dass
der unterschiedliche Funktionen von automatisierten Auswertungen haben.
Die wirken aber manchmal so auch auf mich so ein bisschen unausgegoren.
Also sie machen wohl doch auch Gesichtserkennung im Prinzip bei der Auswertung,
aber da sagt die Polizei ganz vehement, nee, das machen wir nicht.
Und wenn man sich so ein bisschen versucht anzuschauen, was die Polizei da an
Aufnahme und Beobachtung hat,
sieht man, dass sie halt so einen Recording-Server-Computer haben,
der die ganzen Aufzeichnungen speichert.
Und ein paar Arbeitsplätze,
wo man im Prinzip die Videobilder live beobachten kann und diesen ganzen Zoom
und die anderen Kameras drehen und neigen kann.
Aber das heißt, wir sind noch nicht so bei diesem Verhaltensauswertungsthema,
was wir zum Beispiel am Hansaplatz in Hamburg haben, sondern das ist noch so
ein bisschen, ich sag mal, dümmer von dem, was es leisten kann.
Oder siehst du das Potenzial, dass ihr genau diese Art von Verhaltensmusterauswertungsgeschichten,
sag ich mal in Anführungsstrichen, auch bei euch bekommt?
Also so wie der Stand heute ist, wenn wir das, was die Polizei sagt,
ernst nehmen, dann sind das wirklich einfach dumme Videoüberwachungskameras.
Die kann man an einem Bildschirm beobachten, die zeichnen auf und dann kann man sich das speichern.
Also genau einfach so eine standardmäßige Videoüberwachung. Aber mit Blick auf
die Entwicklung, wir haben ja diese AI-Act-Geschichte und gerade sind alle Unternehmen bzw.
Vor allem die Gesetzgeber dabei, so ein bisschen diese Videoüberwachungs-KI-Geschichte
weiter voranzutreiben.
Und da sehen wir auf jeden Fall viel Potenzial, weil wenn die Kameras ausgebaut
werden, dann können wir das im Stadtbild sehr gut sehen.
Da sind neue Masten, da sind Kameras, die überwachen Plätze.
Aber wenn sie hinten an diesem Recording und Beobachtungsplätzen neue Geräte
dazustellen, durch die die Datenströme dann durchfließen, das werden wir nie sehen.
Da müssen wir hoffen, dass die Polizei von sich aus hinkommt und sagt,
okay, wir haben hier neue Maßnahmen etabliert, die sind jetzt halt so.
Und da könnte gegen vorgehen oder nicht.
Ja, aber das hieß ja natürlich wahrscheinlich, zumindest in eurem Bundesland,
in Polizei ist ja Länderrecht, müsste man dafür vermutlich eine gesetzliche Grundlage schaffen.
Wobei man natürlich auch, ich hatte ja vorhin schon angesprochen,
der Wind hat sich ja ein bisschen gedreht bei der Videoüberwachung.
Wahrscheinlich würde man zumindest bei euch im Bundesland auch durchaus Mehrheiten
finden, um davon eine gesetzliche Grundlage zu schaffen.
Also das ist nicht unbedingt ein sehr futuristisches Szenario,
sondern durchaus realitätsrelevant, oder?
Ja, das sehe ich auch so. Also vor allem, wenn man sich anschaut,
die Videoüberwachung hat ja auch irgendjemand im Prinzip ins Gesetz geschrieben.
Und da kann man sich, wenn man versucht, so ein bisschen die Geschichte dahinter
nachzuvollziehen, also die Geschichte von der Videoüberwachung beginnt eigentlich
im Polizeigesetz NRW und dort konkreter Paragraf 15a Polizeigesetz.
Und da wurde die Videoüberwachung 2003 von Rot-Grün eingeführt,
aber auf fünf Jahre befristet.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen das Argument, ja,
ist ja nur befristet, das geht dann ja wieder weg, dann können wir ja sehen,
ob es funktioniert hat oder nicht.
Und genau 2008, so quasi am Ende der Frist, wurde das dann von Schwarz-Gelb verlängert bis 2013.
Also da sieht man so ein bisschen, dass eigentlich sowohl Rot-Grün,
Schwarz-Gelb da diesem Thema aufgeschlossen sind, dass sie das in Gesetze schreiben
oder die Gesetze verlängern.
Und nachdem das dann bis 2013 verlängert wurde,
ging es dann unter Rot-Grün wieder bis 2018 weiter und dann hat endgültig in
2018 die schwarz-gelbe Landesregierung diese Außerkraftsetzungs-Sätze,
genau, es wurde entfristet.
Nee.
Und das vielleicht an dieser Stelle ist das eigentlich eine ganz interessante
Technik, die wir auch irgendwie immer wieder sehen bei allem Möglichen,
dass man immer sagt, okay,
wir machen jetzt Überwachung, aber nur als befristete Ausnahmeregelung und wenn
man dann, ich sag mal, als Gesetzgeber oder als Parlament lang genug wartet,
kann man dann immer sagen, ja, aber wenn wir das jetzt nicht mehr haben,
dann haben wir irgendwie ein Sicherheitsproblem und deswegen müssen wir das
jetzt permanent machen.
Also das ist ja was, was wir häufiger sehen, ist ja bei der Chatkontrolle zum Beispiel auch der Fall.
Da muss man wirklich immer sehr genau hingucken, weil meistens ist natürlich
der Aufschrei initial groß, wenn es solche Ausnahmeregelungen gibt.
Aber je länger die dann irgendwie so mitgeschleppt werden, desto mehr geraten
sie natürlich auch in Vergessenheit.
Und ich glaube, das ist da ja wahrscheinlich, wenn es jetzt eure Klage nicht
gäbe, auch so ein bisschen der Fall, oder?
Richtig, das sehe ich genauso. Also das ist, finde ich, ein sehr schönes Beispiel,
wo man sieht, dass so ein Gesetz über 20 Jahre mitgeschleppt wird und es dann
am Ende noch zu entfristen, weil das hat ja niemandem geschadet.
Na nicht nur das, die Technik hat sich natürlich auch weiterentwickelt,
sowohl bei der rein optischen Technik, wie auch bei der Auswertung.
Das ist ja dann quasi nebenher auch noch passiert, technisch.
Kann ich eine Frage stellen zu diesen, also du hast jetzt sehr viele Informationen
gegeben, so zusammengefasst für die Technik.
In der eigentlichen Verhandlung vor dem Verwaltungsgericht, die auch öffentlich
war, wurde da sehr offen drüber gesprochen oder sind das eher Informationen,
die du jetzt aus den Schriftsätzen hast?
Oder nochmal genereller gesprochen, also wie aufgeschlossen sind sowohl die
Polizei wie auch der Hersteller von Hardware und Software in Bezug auf die Fragen,
die beim Gericht verhandelt wurden?
Und dazu noch sozusagen eine Zusatzfrage ist, kann jemand, der das jetzt nicht
so verfolgt hat, das nachlesen?
Also habt ihr irgendeine Form von Protokoll? Denn aus meiner Erfahrung mit solchen
strategischen Klagen habe ich ja gelernt, dass bei den Gerichten relativ wenig
protokolliert wird, dass man sehr viel selber machen muss,
um sozusagen festzuhalten, was in diesen öffentlichen Verhandlungen eigentlich gesagt wurde.
Ja, also was den Hersteller angeht und die Informationen.
Der Hersteller hat einige Informationen und auch viele Datenblätter auf seiner
Website teilweise veröffentlicht.
Da kann man im Prinzip, wenn man sich dafür interessiert und ein bisschen rumsucht,
findet man da was und kann schon einiges über die verwendete Hardware lernen.
Aber so die eigentlichen Informationen, es gibt auch ein paar Gutachten,
die der Hersteller extra für diesen Prozess oder diese Prozesse geschrieben hat,
um im Prinzip nochmal eine Aussage der Polizei zu untermauern.
Das alles kommt eigentlich nur aus den Schriftsätzen, die ausgetauscht wurden.
Und ich glaube, da können wir nachher nochmal eingehen,
wie genau diese Klagen auch noch weiter strukturiert sind, weil das waren ja
mehrere Verfahren und wir haben an einem Tag im November letzten Jahres einfach
viele Verfahren gleichzeitig behandelt.
Und wir hatten auch so ein bisschen die Sorge, dass es auf der technischen Ebene
Diskussionsbedarf und Erklärungsideen gibt, die in dem Verfahren eine Rolle spielen.
Deshalb hat die Polizei auch einen Mitarbeiter der Firma, die die Kameras hergestellt und verbaut hat.
Eingeladen, im Prinzip mit auf der Seite der Polizei im Gericht zu sitzen,
um bei weiteren Fragen im Prinzip den Mitarbeiter dort sitzen zu haben.
Aber die Fragen wurden gar nicht gestellt und auch gar nicht erläutert,
deshalb das fiel in der Verhandlung komplett hinten runter.
Also ich habe gerade einen Aussetzer. Könnt ihr mich hören?
Ja. Okay. Ich habe noch eine, also direkt dazu noch eine Nachfrage.
Das heißt, die Verhandlung im November 2024,
die habt ihr denn selber protokolliert, sodass ihr wenigstens die Fragen,
die dort angesprochen wurden, auch tatsächlich irgendwie vorliegen habt?
Also auch öffentlich machen könnt?
Oder waren da Pressevertreter dabei? Oder wie habt ihr irgendwie festgehalten,
was in dieser mehrstündigen Verhandlung eigentlich gesagt wurde?
Also einmal waren bei der Verhandlung Vertreter der Presse dabei,
vor allem am Anfang mit so ein bisschen Kameras, um zu schauen,
okay, was passiert eigentlich?
Es gab auch einiges am Publikum, aber quasi niemand der anwesenden Personen
hat die sieben oder acht Stunden Verhandlung bis zur Urteilsverkündigung durchgehalten.
Und deshalb gab es am Ende, als der Gerichtssprecher zum Beispiel durch den
Saal gelaufen ist, um die Pressemitteilung zu verteilen, gab es niemanden,
der die Pressemitteilung haben wollte, weil vor der Presse keiner mehr da war.
Einfach weil es zu lange war.
Richtig, weil ich glaube, wir saßen um 18 Uhr, kurz nach 6, also 18.15 Uhr bei
der Urteilsverkündung, die dann nochmal 20 Minuten gedauert hat.
Das heißt doch, die Lokalpresse, die jetzt aus Köln ist oder eben aus NRW oder
so, die hat sozusagen diesen Prozess dann gar nicht so verfolgt.
Richtig, also die waren auf jeden Fall am Anfang da, aber dann haben sie gesagt,
also wie lange geht denn das noch hier und sind dann irgendwann in einer der
Pausen, die wir eingelegt hatten, dann auch gegangen.
Ja, das habe ich leider, also bei den strategischen Verfahren,
die ich selber verfolgt habe, oder da habe ich das auch so erlebt.
Aber jetzt sag doch mal was zu diesen zusammengezogenen Verfahren,
du hast es jetzt schon zweimal angesprochen.
Also wie setzt sich denn dieses Gerichtsverfahren jetzt zusammen und welche
verschiedenen Verfahren sind zusammengezogen worden?
Richtig. Und zwar haben wir die Klage eingereicht gegen die Videoüberwachung in Köln.
Und da haben wir alle Plätze, die zu dem Zeitpunkt überwacht wurden, in die Klage gefasst.
Und die Klage immer, sobald ein weiterer Platz mit überwacht wurde,
die Klage im Prinzip umgestellt auf, okay, wir haben neun Platz.
Also erweitert quasi.
Genau, erweitert auf die weiteren
Plätze. Und irgendwann ist das Gericht hingegangen und hat gesagt,
ja Moment, also die Plätze müssen wir eigentlich einzeln betrachten,
das können wir nicht in einem Verfahren machen, sondern wir müssen uns genau
angucken, welche Plätze irgendwie dazugehören.
Und dann gab es einen Trennungsbeschluss.
Und in diesem Trennungsbeschluss gab es dann im Prinzip eine neue Klage,
also ein Verfahren mit eigenem Aktenzeichen und allem, was da so dranhängt,
pro Platz, der wie die überwacht wird.
Und dann hatten wir statt im Prinzip einem Verfahren mit diesen Eilverfahren,
die ich ja vorhin schon mal erwähnt hatte, auf einmal sechs Hauptsacheverfahren mehr an der Backe.
Das heißt auch mit den entsprechenden, ich nenne es jetzt mal, Kostenrisiken?
Genau, also ich nenne es einfach mal so mit allen Bugs und Featuren, die dazugehören.
Als Bug ist natürlich einmal das Kostenrisiko und ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das vielleicht als Feature nennen soll, aber ich glaube,
alle Beteiligten haben teilweise bei den Verfahren Copy-Paste gemacht.
Das kann man dann erkennen, wenn sie vergessen, einen Platz irgendwie auf den
richtigen Platz umzustellen. Dann sehen sie, ah ja, ist ja hier alles gleich.
Das sieht man dann irgendwie so als kleine Aufheiterung, dass die alle nur mit Wasser kochen.
Also das bezieht sich jetzt zum Beispiel auf Schriftsätze, die ihr mit den Verfahren
bekommen habt. Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, es sind irgendwie zehn Leitzordner oder so.
Also da läppert sich natürlich dann noch ganz viel, aber da ist eben auch viele doppelt.
Genau das. Da gibt es viele Doppelungen, weil wir uns ja eigentlich am Ende
schon um dieselben Fragen in sieben ähnlich gelagerten Verfahren streiten.
Sag mal das Endziel. Was habt ihr verlangt, was die Richter beim Verwaltungsgericht
für euch erreichen wollen?
Also sag mir mal, was war eure Maximalforderung?
Unsere Maximalforderung war
tatsächlich, dass die Videobachung vollständig eingestellt werden muss.
Also die wird komplett zurückgebaut und ist dann weg. Das war so unsere Maximalforderung,
die wir da mit Klageeinreichung gestellt haben.
Und um mal in Juristen-Deutsch zu sagen, was habt ihr hilfsweise gefordert?
Hilfsweise haben wir verschiedene Dinge gefordert. Und es gibt,
also hilfsweise haben wir zum Beispiel gefordert, die Videoüberwachung zeitlich
einzuschränken, die vorhandene Dokumentation im Prinzip da noch so ein bisschen vorzulegen.
Und genau, also so gut einschränken, wie es geht, auch örtlich immer wieder,
dass es da irgendwie viel zu großflächig ist und bestimmte Bereiche eingeschränkt
werden müssen. Das waren so ein bisschen die Hilfsanträge.
Und wollen wir es jetzt schon offenlegen, also wir sind jetzt,
müssen wir vielleicht mal dazu sagen, hat ja Elina am Anfang schon erwähnt,
wir sind jetzt am Anfang Februar 2025,
willst du mal sagen, wie das Urteil ausging und da ja mittlerweile auch die
Urteilsbegründung vorliegt, wie es begründet wird?
Oder wollen wir die Hörer noch auf die Folter spannen?
Ich denke, wir können das erwähnen. Also wir haben schon einen guten Erfolg erzielt.
Wir sind mit unserer Maximalforderung nicht durchgekommen, aber wir waren auch
ein kleines bisschen überrascht, dass wir doch einiges gewonnen haben.
Und zwar ist das, was hauptsächlich entschieden wurde, die Örtlichkeit muss eingeschränkt werden.
Das heißt, wir haben es geschafft, dass das Verwaltungsgericht gesagt hat,
ungefähr ein Drittel der Plätze, die videoüberwacht werden, dürfen nicht mehr
videoüberwacht werden. Und das ist schon ein signifikanter Teil.
Das Besondere an diesem Ergebnis ist, dass eine Anwohnerin, die in Kalk lebt
und da bei ihr genau diese Situation ist, wie du am Anfang skizziert hast,
Wohngebiet und die Polizei sieht mich jedes Mal, wenn ich aus meiner Haustür
raustrete und ich habe keine Chance, mich dem irgendwie zu entziehen.
Genau das war die Situation bei ihr.
Und der Bereich, der abgeschaltet werden muss, ist genau da, wo sie wohnt.
Das heißt, sie hat im Prinzip dadurch richtig was gewonnen, persönlich.
Ja, aber nun hast du später die Urteilsbegründung bekommen. Das bekommt man
natürlich am selben Tag.
Was hat die Analyse dieser Urteilsbegründung ergeben?
Ja, die Analyse der Urteilsbegründung, die war auch so ein bisschen spannend.
Und also sie war schon, okay, vielleicht nochmal, es war so ein bisschen das,
was auch in der Gerichtsverhandlung im Großen und Ganzen gesagt wurde.
Du hattest ja vorhin gefragt, wie ist das mit Protokollführen,
was da alles besprochen wurde.
Da hast du völlig recht, da gibt es vom Gericht her eigentlich nichts,
was man dann mit nach Hause nehmen kann, sondern man muss sich selbst darum kümmern.
Da habe ich mich auch so ein bisschen in dem Verfahren im November darum zu
kümmern, das alles zu protokollieren.
Aber der Richter hatte bei dem Verfahren auch direkt am Anfang gesagt,
wir reden hier von über 1500 Seiten Verfahrensmaterial.
Wir können in dieser mündlichen Verhandlung nicht auf jeden Aspekt eingehen
im Detail, sondern wir müssen uns schon die Sachen raussuchen,
die hier für die Entscheidung relevant sind und das haben sie getan.
Die Kammer selbst hat nach meinem Gefühl her nicht wirklich viel Diskussion zugelassen.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt irgendwie, also man könnte hingehen und sagen,
das Urteil war schon eigentlich vorgeschrieben in der Schublade und das wurde
dann am Ende nur noch ergänzt durch irgendwelche kleinen Hinweise oder nochmal
kleineren Entscheidungen.
Aber am Ende war das schon so ein bisschen die grundsätzliche Idee,
die das Gericht vorher in der Vorbereitung auf diese mündliche Verhandlung vorbereitet
hat und so war es dann auch.
Deshalb, es wurden verschiedene Rechtspositionen erörtert und da war eigentlich
immer der Kommentar vom Vorsitzenden Richter, ich kann auch diese Rechtsauffassung verstehen,
wir haben aber eine andere und wenn sie ein Problem damit haben,
können sie ja die nächste Instanz geben, was ich vermute, was sie sowieso machen.
Und damit war dann im Prinzip jedes Thema immer abgefrühstückt.
Ja, also das heißt, dem Richter am Verwaltungsgericht war auch schon klar,
dass ihr eventuell den Instanzenweg sucht, aber nur sagt doch mal was dazu.
Werdet ihr den Instanzenweg suchen und wie hat die Polizei oder vielleicht sogar
die Politik, wenn sie dann reagiert hat, wie haben sie sich auf das Urteil sozusagen
in einer Reaktion bezogen?
Also einmal bei der Politik habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht viel vernommen,
aber die Presse hat so größtenteils gesagt, über Videoüberwachung in Köln zu großflächig.
Und das hat uns auch so ein bisschen überrascht, dass die Presse da durchaus
mal ein bisschen stärkere Kritik an dieser Videoüberwachung durchklingen lässt,
dass das eher als Problem dargestellt wird und nicht als die Lösung.
Und das hat schon mal geholfen.
Von der Polizei selbst haben wir gar keine Äußerungen jetzt großartig gesehen,
außer dass sie das Urteil prüfen werden und so weiter und so fort.
Aber es gibt noch keine offizielle Reaktion im Sinne von, das lassen wir uns aber so nicht gefallen?
Es gibt eine Reaktion, dass sie Berufung in allen Klagen, also in allen Verfahren eingelegt haben.
Das heißt, egal ob wir jetzt Stratege, also wenn wir jetzt sagen würden,
okay, das Ergebnis stellt uns zufrieden genug, wir belassen es dabei.
Das ist vorbei, das können wir nicht hier machen, weil die Polizei Berufung
eingelegt hat und das Verfahren in die nächste Instanz erzwingen wird,
ob wir darauf Lust haben oder nicht.
Habt ihr denn darauf Lust?
Also das Zwischenergebnis ist schon gut.
Wir reden jetzt natürlich auch davon, dass wir über sieben Jahre an diesem Thema dranhängen.
Das ist natürlich auch so echt ein anstrengendes Projekt, was durchaus Zeit
und Energie und Ressourcen bindet.
Und da sind wir vermutlich eher so ein bisschen im Nachteil im Gegensatz zur
Polizei, weil die als Behörde da genug Ressourcen haben.
Und wir haben entschieden, dass wir auch in Berufung gehen,
denn wir wollen schauen, dass wir,
weil das wird ja in der Berufungsverhandlung dann vor dem Oberverwaltungsgericht
NRW, also quasi die nächste Instanz, dann eh behandelt werden,
dass wir gucken, dass die Themen, mit denen wir nicht zufrieden sind,
auch nochmal aufgreifen, um zu schauen,
ob das Oberverwaltungsgericht da vielleicht eine andere Meinung hat als das Verwaltungsgericht.
Nun ist es ja zumindest, soweit ich das weiß, so, dass das Überverwaltungsgericht
nicht nochmal sozusagen eine Tatsachenaufnahme macht.
Also die werden jetzt nicht nochmal von Pontius Pilatus allein zu den Punkten
besprechen, sondern die werden sich ja vor allen Dingen damit beschäftigen,
was konkret in den Berufungen drin steht, nicht wahr?
Wo wollt ihr dahin zählen? Also wo schießt ihr hinten sozusagen?
Genau, das ist völlig richtig. Wir können nicht irgendwie komplett neue Sachverhalte
oder Argumente in das Verfahren vor dem Oberverwaltungsgericht einbringen.
Wir müssen uns schon darauf stützen, was bisher diskutiert wurde und worum es
hier so ein bisschen geht. Und da sind verschiedene Sachen, die wir nochmal aufgreifen wollen.
Da geht es natürlich einmal um die zeitliche Dimension von der Videoüberwachung.
Wir sind nach wie vor der Meinung, dass 24-7 nicht verhältnismäßig ist.
Die Flächen werden wir auch nochmal im Prinzip angreifen und ja,
im Prinzip so ein bisschen alle Argumente, die vorgebracht wurden,
es geht zum Beispiel auch um die Speicherdauer,
das Material wird 14 Tage lang gespeichert nach der Aufzeichnung und da finden
wir auch, dass das zu lange ist.
Die andere Frage, die sich auch so ein bisschen aus verfahrenstaktischer Sicht
stellt, wie die Polizei hat Berufung eingelegt, aber wir kennen Stand heute
die Berufungsgründe noch nicht.
Das heißt, wir wissen auch nicht, welche Punkte die Polizei angreifen wird.
Und da müssen wir halt auch schauen, dass wir dagegen halten.
Wie ist es denn? Hilft euch jemand? Also gibt es eine Behörde zum Beispiel,
also die schon angesprochene Datenschutzbeauftragte oder andere NGOs oder also
gibt es da jemand, der euch unter die Arme greift?
Also jetzt mal abgesehen vom Chaos Computer Club, aber ich meine, habt ihr Hilfe?
Ja, leider ist die Hilfe von der Datenschutzbeauftragten eher so mäßig.
Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, die Datenschutzbeauftragte ist theoretisch
froh, dass wir ihre Arbeit machen.
Weil die haben gemerkt, dass es mit der, also die haben ja auch viel zu tun,
die sind ja auch so ein bisschen langatmig, die haben ja schon auch etwas gemacht,
was die Videoüberwachung angeht, aber die sehen halt auch, dass die Polizei
nicht mit den Entscheidungen von der Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde einverstanden
ist und müssen das dann wahrscheinlich auch versuchen,
irgendwie gerichtlich zu klären und warum sollen die da Personal und Ressourcen aufstellen,
wenn wir das machen für die.
Deswegen sehe ich da auch wenig Perspektive, dass sie uns da großartig unterstützen wird.
Sonst haben wir nicht besonders viel Unterstützung.
Also natürlich unterstützt uns der CCC, aber sonst ist das auch ein Thema,
was so eben, wenn man das so ein bisschen gesellschaftlich betrachtet,
nicht ein Thema ist, wo wir sehen, okay, Videoüberwachung ist auf jeden Fall
ein Problem und das müssen wir so ein bisschen zurückdrängen, wir helfen euch gerne.
Sondern das ist schon so ein Ding, das haben wir auch teilweise auf der Straße
erlebt, dass Leute Videoüberwachung fordern, um sich endlich sicher zu fühlen.
Und das ist dann immer so ein bisschen schwierig, da auch weiter Unterstützung zu bekommen.
An der Stelle muss man natürlich immer sagen, Videoüberwachung sorgt natürlich
nicht für mehr Sicherheit.
Ich glaube, wir sind uns da klar drüber, aber ich würde es an dieser Stelle
nochmal sehr deutlich sagen, da gibt es ja auch Studien zu, dass es jetzt nicht
unbedingt dafür sorgt, dass es weniger Kriminalität gibt, wenn es mehr Videoüberwachung gibt.
Aber so zum Thema Unterstützung, ich glaube, wen es da natürlich schon gibt
und das ist natürlich das Erste, was mir in den Kopf kommt, ist natürlich die
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
die ja eigentlich genau solche Sachen in der Regel unterstützt.
Und Konstanze hatte auch ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung mit der GFF,
gegen bestimmte Dinge vorzugehen.
Und ist da jetzt irgendwie was in Aussicht, dass ihr mit der GFF zusammenarbeitet
oder ist das noch zu klein?
Also das müssen wir auf jeden Fall schauen.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Kontakte und es wurde uns auch schon gesagt,
wir machen das ja schon ganz gut,
zumindest am Anfang, als er damit so ein bisschen begonnen hat und jetzt nach
dem ersten Urteil in der Hauptsache wollen wir uns mit denen noch ein bisschen
mehr unterhalten, um zu schauen,
bekommen wir da vielleicht noch ein bisschen Unterstützung.
Weil, wie ich auch vorhin erwähnte, da werden schon ein paar grundsätzliche
Fragen geklärt, was auch im Bereich der Grundrechte vielleicht möglicherweise
einige Auswirkungen hat.
Na nun haben wir ja bei Dicke Bretter, wir machen ja mittlerweile schon ein
ganzes Jahr lang Dicke Bretter, sogar schon mehr als ein Jahr.
Nun hatten wir öfter mal so Initiativen oder Leute, die sich langfristig engagieren
und die eben versuchen, so eine strategischen Fragen klären zu lassen.
Sag doch mal aus deiner Sicht, was für eine Art von Unterstützung kannst du dir denn vorstellen?
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwo bin, ich bin vielleicht nicht irgendwo in Kölner,
sondern ich komme aus, weiß ich doch nicht, Rostock oder Potsdam.
Aber ich finde, ihr habt da einen wichtigen Fall oder ich sehe in meiner eigenen
Stadt ähnliche Bestrebungen.
Was würdest du dir denn wünschen, wie Leute sich vielleicht engagieren oder
hast du vielleicht Ideen?
Da gibt es einige Ideen, was man vielleicht machen könnte oder sollte.
Also einerseits ist es natürlich hilfreich, so ein bisschen konkretere Unterstützung
in diesen Verfahren zu bekommen, weil sieben oder teilweise mehr als sieben
Verfahren parallel zu betreiben, ist schon so ein gewisser Aufwand.
Bei dem Unterstützung durch andere dann noch hilfreich ist.
Das Problem daran ist dann manchmal, die Leute gleichzeitig im Prinzip in dieses
Verfahren einzuführen, weil ich hatte es ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnt,
das ist schon so ein besonders dickes Brett mit über 1500 Seiten und damit muss
man dann erstmal umgehen und sich so ein bisschen reinfuchsen.
Und das ist einerseits so ein Problem, aber andererseits versuchen wir auch
immer durch Stadtspaziergänge, durch Videoüberwachungsbereiche,
die wir auch als Versammlungen anmelden, so ein bisschen die Leute aufzuklären,
was passiert hier, wie sieht das hier aus in der Stadt?
Und auch darüber zu informieren, dass Videoüberwachung vielleicht gar nicht
so das tut, was man jetzt glaubt, was es tut.
Und da haben wir dann auch oft das Feedback, dass die Leute die Videoüberwachung
gar nicht so wirklich wahrnehmen, sondern die ist halt da.
Man hat vielleicht anderes im Kopf. Und da, genau, so öffentlichkeitsmäßig wäre
Unterstützung auch praktisch, aber ist halt auch eher schwierig.
Aber vielleicht um jetzt nicht so auf dieser, wir brauchen Unterstützung,
es klingt jetzt alles so ein bisschen, es ist natürlich sehr müßig, dieses ganze Thema.
Und ich glaube auch erstmal so eine Klage aufzurollen ist ja auch sehr müßig.
Und der Papierkram, der damit kommt, ist auch müßig. Aber ich glaube, er ist total wichtig.
Jetzt vielleicht so zum Abschluss, was man so mitnehmen kann.
Ich denke, auf jeden Fall dieses Thema klagen oder gegen solche Dinge vorgehen
oder Fakten schaffen ist, denke ich, ein wichtiges Vorgehen.
Eins, was wir wahrscheinlich auch perspektivisch in den nächsten paar Jahren sehr viel brauchen.
Oh yeah.
Ja, genau. Und ich glaube, es ist auch ein wichtiges Tool.
Was hast du so aus diesen letzten, ich wollte gerade sagen gefühlt zehn Jahren,
aber es sind tatsächlich fast zehn Jahre, irgendwie mitgenommen?
Also außer Klagen lohnt sich. Ihr habt schon echt was geschafft.
Aber was würdest du so jemandem mitgeben wollen jetzt so auf den letzten Metern?
Was sollte man beachten und sollte man es überhaupt machen?
Da wäre für mich irgendwie ein klares Ja, weil es ein total wichtiges Ermächtigungstool ist. Genau.
Ja, also ich glaube, dass das Wichtigste ist, was man tun kann, ist Bildetbanden.
Also das funktioniert eigentlich nur als Projekt, bei dem mehr als zwei Personen mit dran ziehen.
Man sollte schon so eine Gruppe haben, die sich Aufgaben teilen kann,
wenn jemand ausfällt, vielleicht sich um Nachwuchs kümmern kann.
Also das ist schon eigentlich essentiell.
Parallel muss man auch so ein bisschen auf diese finanzielle Seite immer so
schauen und man sollte auch gucken, wie langatmig sowas werden kann,
also so perspektivisch,
wie du schon sagst, da hänge ich vielleicht dann bald irgendwann zehn Jahre drin in diesem Projekt.
Und das sollte man sich natürlich auch vorher klar machen, dass dieses Thema
einen selbst vielleicht die
nächsten Jahre dominieren wird, weil ich habe es ja auch vorhin erwähnt,
wenn das Oberverwaltung, wenn die Polizei Berufung einlegt und in die nächste
Instanz geht, also in die zweite dann vom Oberverwaltungsgericht,
da kann man dann schlecht einfach sagen, okay,
ich habe jetzt keine Lust mehr, das waren schöne sieben, acht Jahre,
ich gehe jetzt, tschüssi.
Das funktioniert da natürlich nicht so wirklich, außer man möchte das dann verlieren.
Das heißt, ich glaube, das machen sich viele nicht klar, dass man sich wirklich
langfristig engagieren muss.
Allerdings hat man nämlich über die Jahre auch einen Vorteil.
Der besteht natürlich darin einfach, dass man Kompetenzen aufbaut,
nicht nur juristische, sondern technische, sondern aber auch Verfahrenskompetenzen.
Man weiß dann so langsam, wie es läuft.
Ich wünsche mir manchmal, da gäbe ich mehr Erfahrungsweitergabe,
weil viele, glaube ich, jeder selber lernen muss und ein bisschen schade drum.
Insofern finde ich ganz gut, dass ihr auf der Webseite auch eine ganze Menge
Prozesswissen niedergelegt habt.
Wollen wir die Webseite nochmal erwähnen?
Auf jeden Fall.
Niedergeschriebenes Prozesswissen ist ja unser Lieblingsthema.
Wir versuchen das ja auch irgendwie immer so ein bisschen festzuhalten.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du, Konstanze, da auch noch mehr drüber sagen.
Du bist ja ein alter Hase, was solche Sachen angeht. Wobei deine Verfahren sind
alle gerade im Stocken, oder?
Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht. Ich habe eins tatsächlich, gerade mit den Gesundheitsdaten
und der Zentralisierung der Gesundheitsdaten, die immer noch in Berlin vor Gericht
liegt und gerade so stockt. Das stimmt.
Also ein strategisches Verfahren zusammen mit der GFF.
Genau, da sieht man es dann nämlich, das stockt irgendwie alles an irgendeinem
Punkt, entweder weil technische Voraussetzungen fehlen oder sonstige Dinge.
Also an dieser Stelle eine herzliche Einladung. Schaut bei kameras-stoppen.org
vorbei, wenn ihr weitere Informationen zu diesen Prozessen haben wollt.
Snoopy findet man auf Mastodon, wenn ich das jetzt so verraten darf. Genau, richtig.
Ganz unnötig mit so einem Hunde-Logo.
Und dann würde ich sagen, vielen Dank für diesen großen Load an Informationen, Snoopy.
Dankeschön. Das ist ja ein mühsiges Thema.
Vielen Dank für deine Arbeit und nochmal herzlichen Glückwunsch zu diesem Etappensieg, sage ich mal so.
Und wir, ja, Snoopy, möchtest du noch letzte Worte?
Vielen Dank, dass ich das kurz beleuchten durfte. Es ist ja einfach ein dickes
Brett, deswegen fand ich das auch sehr passend.
Sehr schön dann, ja ich glaube Konz, wir müssen diesem Thema noch mehr Zeit
widmen in den nächsten paar Folgen damit wir besser gewappnet sind für das was uns da dann ab dem 23.
Februar erwartet ich schließe hiermit, vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt,
wir freuen uns auf das nächste Mal, vielleicht mit unserer Mitstreiterin Elisa,
die ich jetzt unerwähnt gelassen habe aber ich habe gehört, sie ist in der aktuellsten
Chaos-Radio-Folge zu hören.
Dementsprechend hören wir uns in zwei Monaten wahrscheinlich wieder mit einem neuen Thema.
Falls ihr Themenvorschläge habt, freuen wir uns natürlich auch über Themenvorschläge.
Und ansonsten lest uns auf
Netzpolitik.org an dieser Stelle auch nochmal vielen Dank für das Veröffentlichen
von unseren Gesprächen und natürlich wie immer Ein großes Dankeschön an die
Chaos-Radio-Crew fürs Schneiden und Online-Stellen unserer Episoden.
Ohne die wäre das so natürlich nicht möglich.
Und damit vielen Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss. Tschüss.
Tschüss.